Was war zuerst da:
Das Huhn oder das Ei?
Diese Frage klären wir
hier und jetzt ein für allemal!
(Musik)
Hühner legen Eier.
Und aus Eiern schlüpfen Hühner.
Irgendwann, vor langer Zeit,
muss es das allererste Huhn oder
das allererste Ei gegeben haben!
Hühner gab es ja nicht schon immer.
Das heutige Huhn ist übrigens der
engste lebende Verwandte des T-Rex!
Wenn der wüsste,
was aus ihm geworden ist!
Da die Dinos schon Eier legten,
ist das Ei natürlich
viel älter als das Huhn.
Die korrekte Frage müsste lauten:
Was war zuerst da,
das Huhn oder das Hühnerei?
Das Huhn muss sich also irgendwann
als Spezies entwickelt haben.
Neue Spezies entwickeln sich
durch kleine Veränderungen
in der DNA ihrer Vorgänger.
Das Kopieren der DNA bei der
Fortpflanzung ist nie 100% akkurat.
Es kommt immer
zu kleinen "Mutationen".
Manche Mutationen
können z.B. zu Krankheiten führen.
Andere Mutationen können aber auch
vorteilhaft für den Organismus sein.
Durch so eine DNA-Mutation
kann ein Organismus z.B.
besser an seine Umwelt
angepasst werden.
Solche Mutationen
können dann vererbt werden
und sich zu einer neuen Spezies
entwickeln.
Natürlich ist Evolution
ein langer, gradueller Prozess.
D.h. die direkten Vorfahren
des Huhns waren dem Huhn
genetisch schon sehr ähnlich
und dem T-Rex schon sehr unähnlich.
Aber irgendwann wurde das erste Huhn
von 2 Nicht-Hühnern erzeugt!
Und zwar so: Die DNA des männlichen
Spermas und die des weiblichen Eis
werden kombiniert,
und es entsteht die "Zygote".
Die Zygote ist die allererste Zelle
des Hühnerbabys!
In jedem Tier und auch in uns
enthält jede Zelle
genau dieselbe DNA!
Nämlich die der Zygote,
der allerersten Zelle!
Also: Irgendwann
vereinten sich 2 Nicht-Hühner
und die DNA ihrer Zygote
enthielt die nötigen Mutationen,
um das erste Huhn darzustellen!
Vor dieser Zygote
gab es nur Nicht-Hühner!
Die Zygote war die erste Zelle
mit Hühner-DNA.
Und da sich diese Zygotenzelle
im Ei befindet,
ist die Antwort auf das Rätsel:
Das Ei war zuerst da!
Aber: Jetzt seid ihr gefragt!
Das war die Biologie dazu, aber eine
Sache ist biologisch nicht geklärt.
Und zwar, wie genau
ein Hühnerei definiert ist.
Denn, wie gesagt,
geht es nicht um Huhn und Ei,
sondern um Huhn und Hühnerei!
Wir haben geklärt,
dass das erste Huhn
mit der ersten Hühnerzygote
entstand.
Aber: Darf man das Ei,
in dem diese Zygote heranwächst,
schon "Hühnerei" nennen?
Oder ist erst das Ei,
das dieses erste Huhn legt,
das erste richtige Hühnerei?
Wenn das so wäre,
dann war das Huhn doch zuerst da.
Und hier kommen wir
zur entscheidenden Frage:
Was ist ein Hühnerei?
Ist ein Hühnerei ein Ei,
das von einem Huhn gelegt wird?
Oder ist ein Hühnerei ein Ei,
aus dem ein Huhn schlüpft?
Die Frage wird klarer, wenn man
sie sich etwas absurder stellt:
Stellt euch vor,
ein Hase würde ein Ei legen.
Und aus dem Ei schlüpft ein Igel.
Ist dieses Ei jetzt
ein Hasen-Ei oder ein Igel-Ei?
Stimmt hier oben ab oder
schreibt es in die Kommentare
und dann klären wir diese Frage
ein für allemal!
Schönschlau!
Untertitel: ARD Text
i.A. von Funk (2017)
Ich wünsche euch ein wunderschönes
Osterfest, mit oder ohne Eier!
Jedenfalls wisst ihr jetzt,
was ihr antworten könnt,
wenn euch jemand mit dem
Henne-oder-Ei-Problem kommt.
Wir sehen uns
nächsten Donnerstag wieder.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.